es ist eine eigene Welt die Welt von Btl
einer jüdischen Siedlung nördlich von
ramalla im von Israel besetzten
Westjordanland 6000 israelische Siedler
Leben hier und auch mehr ihrer und
Benjamin sitzner wollen sich in bate l
eine Existenz aufbauen das die von
Gewalt und Konflikten geprägt sein wird
nimmt das frisch vermählte Paar in Kauf
ich werde bald eine Pistole beantragen
jedes Mal wenn wir weltel verlassen
fragen wir uns was tun wir wenn ein
Stein nach uns geworfen wird was wenn
ein Molotowcocktail fliegt was wenn
Araber eine Straßensperre errichten und
auf der Autobahn einen milchversuch
starten
ganz Btl ist von einem bewachten Zaun
umgeben dass die Siedlungen nach
internationalem Recht illegal sind und
auch Siedler und Soldaten Gewalt gegen
Palästinenser ausüben blendet 17er aus
die
arabischen Städte sind nicht von einem
Zaun umgeben denn es besteht keine
Gefahr dass ein Jude in eine arabische
Stadt eindringt und versucht einen
Terrorangriff zu verüben
83% der Einwohner die religiösen
Zionisten gewählt ein rechtsextremes
Parteien Bündnis dass eine harte Linie
gegen Araber fordert auch Benjamin und
mir ihrer haben die Zionisten gewählt
und deren Anführer
ittermar wenn wir
wirklich zurückbringen möchte heißt auf
Hebräisch Ordnung
und was bin gewirrunter Ordnung versteht
hat er in seiner Laufbahn ausreichend
deutlich gemacht vorher schafft der
Juden und Konfrontation mit den Arabern
in Israel und den besetzten
Palästinenser Gebieten dutzende Male
wurde er verurteilt wegen Vandalismus
wegen rassistischer Volksverhetzung
wegen Unterstützung einer
terroristischen Vereinigung Mal will er
das Westjordanland annektieren mal
unliebsame araberausweisen
Jakob Perry Ex-Chef des
Inlandsgeheimdienstes beobachtet bengv
seit dessen Jugend
die behaupten jüdische Vorherrschaft sei
seine Ideologie haben Recht
der hasst fremde
er hat alle die nicht jüdischen Glaubens
sind er ist gegen jede Vermischung gegen
jede Verbindung von Juden und Arabern
trotzdem hat Benjamin netanjau bin würde
den Steigbügel zur Macht gehalten
erstmals in der Geschichte Israels
könnten bald rechtsextreme
ultra-nationalisten am Kabinettstisch
sitzen
immer wieder provoziert Benk wir mit
Auftritten wie vor der al-axa Moschee
auf dem Tempelberg fordert mehr jüdische
Kontrolle über das Heiligtum für Muslime
ein Sakrileg
in Ost Jerusalem zückte er noch im
Oktober bei einer Straßenschlacht seine
Pistole und forderte die Umstehenden
Polizisten auf Steine werfen der Araber
niederzuschießen
während des Wahlkampfs und danach noch
einmal explizit in einem offenen Brief
an seine Zitat Brüder von der Linken
erklärte Ben Girl er sei erwachsen
geworden er habe sich geändert
journalistische Beobachter wie der
Chefredakteur der Jerusalem Post halten
das für ein Täuschungsmanöver
ich glaube nicht dass er erwachsen
geworden ist das ist Show ein Trick um
zu zeigen dass er gemäßigter geworden
ist um Leute zu gewinnen die sich sonst
abwenden würden abgeschreckt von diesen
rassistischen faschistischen
extremistischen Ansichten und es hat
funktioniert so haben Sie die Zahl ihrer
Stimmen vergrößert
sich auch gestern staatstragend bei
einem Treffen mit Polizei führen in
Israel als Minister für innere
Sicherheit will er deren Vorgesetzter
werden ein Brandstifter im Chefsessel
fürchten viele
so wie usama de kedek er lebt in einem
arabischen Viertel im von Israel
annektierten Ostjerusalem gleich
gegenüber von seinem Haus steht wie
verloren ein Zelt Büro des
knesset-abgeordneten Band wirstädterin
geschrieben immer wieder taucht der hier
auf um Druck auf die Einwohner auszuüben
die sich gegen Zwangsräumungen wehren
die sind nach Ansicht von un und EU
völkerrechtswidrig
erst betet er
dann fängt er an zu telefonieren mit
anderen Rassisten
manchmal sagt er er brauche 500 Leute
die herkommen sollen
immer wieder kommt es hier zu
Zusammenstößen und Zerstörungen
befürchtet dass der Konflikt noch
gewalttätiger wird denn ein wenn wir
werde sich niemals ändern
niemals niemals von hier bis zum Himmel
der schlecht ist bleibt schlecht und
wird sich nicht ändern
dann würde er ja alle seine Stimmen in
der Knesset verlieren und seine ganze
Popularität bei den Juden die er nur
bekommen hat wegen seiner Verfolgung und
Terrorisierung von Palästinensern
und es droht noch eine Gefahr die
religiösen Zionisten wollen zusammen mit
ultra-orthodoxen und Teilen des Liquid
schnellstmöglich ein Gesetz einbringen
mit dem Urteile des Obersten
Gerichtshofs von der Knesset überstimmt
werden können das wäre ein Angriff auf
die Gewaltenteilung auf den
demokratischen Rechtsstaat
sie könnten den demokratischen Charakter
Israels untergraben sie wollen das macht
Gleichgewicht verändern zwischen
Exekutive Parlament und Rechtsprechung
das würde Israel Verändern von einer
liberalen hin zu einer autoritären
Demokratie
auch Benjamin sitzner hat so seine
Vorstellung von der Zukunft Israels eine
eigener Start der Palästinenser hat
darin keinen Platz bestenfalls die
Integration der Araber in ein groß
Israel
wir müssen darüber diskutieren ob die
Araber die hier leben Bürger von Israel
werden wollen und an der Gesellschaft
teilhaben wollen statt aktiv gegen den
jüdischen und demokratischen Charakter
des Staates zu kämpfen
doch danach sieht es nicht aus falls die
Extremisten an die Regierung kommen er
nach einer Vertiefung der Gräben
zwischen Juden und Palästinensern und
nach einer weiteren Eskalation der
Gewalt